including on the need to continue our
strong support for ukraine
both in the short term but also over the
longer term and i look forward to
welcoming president celensky to address
nato leaders at our summit in madrid
in response to russia's invasion we have
reinforced our ability to protect and
defend every inch of nato allied
territory in madrid we will take the
next steps and agree a major
strengthening of our posture
tonight we discussed the need for more
robust and combat ready forward presence
even higher readiness and more
pre-positioned equipment and supplies
we also address the need to invest more
in our defence and to invest more
together to strengthen nato's common
funding
in madrid we will agree nato's next
strategic concept it will assess our
changed security environment and
reaffirm our fundamental values and
tasks and it will be a blueprint for
alliance's future
finally we also discussed
finland and sweden's historic
applications
for joining nato their membership will
make them safer and our alliance
stronger
i had constructive talks with president
elina and prime minister anderson during
my visit to finland and sweden earlier
this week
and i welcome the serious steps already
taken to address turkey's concerns
including the fight against pkk
dialogue continues to find united way
forward asked critical questions
are we sufficiently strong in defending
our european values
in ukraine the ukrainian soldiers and
people of ukraine fight for the most
important
european
and free world values
sovereignty freedom
rights to live
and
other critical values and i think the
answer is
no we are not doing enough we
we have not done enough to
defend ukraine to
support ukrainian people to defend their
freedom and sovereignty i urge you i ask
you to do much more to
deliver
weapon
artillery
to ukraine they
need this to defend
their country to defend their
territorial integrity and sovereignty
uh on their
road to the european union we support
giving them
the candidate status us
as quickly as possible because ukrainian
people
need hope and this is their major hope
for the future i think he did not count
on two things one he did not count
on the resistance
of the ukrainian people in the ukrainian
army
and two i don't think he counted on the
reaction that we
in europe and in nato uh have had and
that is he has
pushed us together
and reunited us in a way that
maybe we have not had this sense of
purpose
for many years